what's going on guys this is rob and one
of you had this idea down in the
comments you said hey like you should
kind of give us your your views or your
ideas on
what movies will look like in phase six
right because phase five is basically
done i mean we have like a couple other
projects like a few other projects but
we're literally at the tail end phase
six i think is where a lot of the
interest is because there's a lot of
things that we just don't know now at
the time that we're recording this video
d23 is give or take a few days about a
month away so we know that like more
information about phase six is likely
going to be announced there possibly
some plot details most likely some
projects that are going to get release
dates that we just simply didn't see at
san diego comic con x-men different
things like that for the fantastic four
kevin feige recently came out and said
and i quote here a lot of people know
this origin a lot of people know the
basics how do we take that and bring
something that they've never seen before
we've set a very high bar for ourselves
with bringing that to the screen now of
course there was a little bit of
expansion here and effectively what
kevin feige said is the fantastic four
film is not going to be an origin story
so it's not gonna feel like iron man one
or captain america one or thor one and
it kind of makes sense i think for a
variety of reasons we're sort of past
the days of like the traditional origin
story type film coming out of the mcu
it's not to say we won't get those but i
think they'll happen through different
means or only for characters that people
just basically know nothing about which
is like 90 of the characters that they
can introduce in the mcu but if it's not
going to be an origin film then the
question has to be asked what kind of
film are we going to be seeing now this
is where i think things have the
potential to become exponentially
interesting with the fantastic four if
we take kevin feige's words literally
and we say okay this is not an origin
film it's going to be a movie that's
basically going to throw the fantastic
four to us but it's going to be done in
like a holy [ __ ] kind of way then that
means they got to pull out all the stops
now fantastic four initiates phase six
the ending of phase six is king dynasty
and secret wars just based on these
titles alone which i think it was very
intentional for why they gave us these
titles i think they're telling us
exactly the role that fantastic four are
going to have i think it's planned out
there's no script writer john watts left
the projects they don't have a director
and nobody's been cast but it doesn't
mean they don't know what the general
premise of the film is going to be what
i think is going to happen is that for a
lot of you all out there that have this
theory and saying that the fantastic
four have been around since the 60s but
they're time displaced i think you're
right but i think what they're gonna do
is they're gonna have the fantastic four
at least they're gonna establish it in
some capacity that they previously faced
off against ramat now for those of you
guys who don't know who that is rama
taught was kane the conqueror's attempt
to go back into the past and to
initially try to conquer ancient egypt
which he successfully did and then
expand his fear of influence out from
there now over the years with stories
like the adventures of cyclops and
phoenix different things like that what
they did is they introduced villains
like apocalypse they gave him an origin
by way of rama tut and so on and so
forth but what it would do is it would
bring kane the conqueror in in a more
tangible way and saying this guy is more
than just a dude who exists in the
far-flung future with a line in quantum
mania where he asked scott lang didn't i
kill you at some point that with there
being multiple versions of this guy
across the multiverse surely our main
marvel cinematic universe has one we
don't know if the version of kang that
scotland is going to see in ant-man 3
quantomania if that's our king the
conqueror or just a maine king the
conqueror and if they want to introduce
the fantastic four in a really
interesting way and bring in rama tut
the best way to do it is to say that our
marvel cinematic universe earth 616 king
the conqueror had gone back into the
past became ramatat and then was
ultimately defeated by the fantastic
four but surely this fight between rama
tut and the fantastic four has not been
going on all this time and surely if the
fight lasted a few days the fantastic
four likely would have found their way
back and they could basically return
seemingly the moment they left so the
question is why wouldn't that
necessarily happen well here's my
thought my thought kind of takes that a
step further and basically we would see
the plot of sliders not an exact plot
but just more of something similar to it
so for those of you guys who never saw
sliders it was a great show way back in
the day but you basically had a handful
of folks who were essentially lost in
the time stream they kept trying to find
their way back to their earth but they
ended up finding other earth instead
ended up traveling to other alternate
realities instead and it was just a
really cool way for the show to give us
like alternate realities like what if
the british had won the revolutionary
war different things along those lines
now i would have a hard time believing
that somebody as intelligent as reed
richards wouldn't have the ability to
simply just access the quantum realm and
then return back to the main marvel
universe instead what i think would
actually happen here is it'd be one of
those things where they're like okay
like let's go back to our timeline and
maybe like something happens they get
thrown off course they end up in an
alternate reality they basically have
the opportunity to come back after
ending up in that alternate universe and
exploring it and then they're just kind
of like i mean what if we explored some
more like what if we what if we just
didn't go back right now i mean
technically we're manipulating time we
could feasibly just go back to the
moment we left right like literally we
see ourselves disappearing
right like i mean we could do that so
it's not like we lose a whole bunch of
time and that's basically it and what
the fantastic four have been doing all
this time is exploring the multiverse
but what you can in turn do and this is
i think a really great way to roll in
both the events of king dynasty in phase
six as well as building on the events of
loki as you could say okay as they're
exploring the multiverse they're like
okay this is interesting this is cool
this is you know really really unique
and then suddenly things start changing
around them and the idea of things
changing around them is the result of
this sacred timeline rejoining the rest
of the multiverse and that's when they
start to realize something's off right
like now you have kang or a series of
kings a council of kang's the kang
dynasty if they want to call it that but
they start to realize something's wrong
with the multiverse now maybe they
explore a little bit more and they
realize okay so like there's this big
bad guy kang he's the one that like
we're literally like we have to avoid
perhaps king is chasing after them i
don't really know but the overall gist
of this is they return to the main
marvel cinematic universe and they're
the ones that basically make it possible
for the heroes to learn about king the
conqueror to learn what he's capable of
and what he can do the only alternative
to that is to find some way to invoke
sylvie after she had killed he who
remains and then bring her into the fold
assuming she wasn't immediately killed
by kang when he sees power but with this
being the case i think it stands to
reason that it would make a phenomenal
fantastic four film that is basically a
movie that shows the team exploring the
multiverse instead of just going back
home and then in turn they basically see
the effects of the events of sylvie
killing immortus right he who remains
and how that affects the greater
multiverse and then it's through their
eyes that we actually start to see how
far reaching the influence of kang is
that these different versions of kang
all rule in different ways and that the
multiverse itself isn't a state of
absolute chaos and absolute flux it's by
them that we end up getting the full
totality of just how screwed up things
are this leads to them by whatever
manner and whatever means returning to
the marvel cinematic universe and being
the way in which the avengers are able
to unify and potentially defeat cain the
conqueror if we want to take this a step
further and we want to make the
fantastic four even more essential here
what we can say is that sure scott lang
has the ability to access the quantum
realm we don't know how far reaching his
ability to access the quantum realm is
can he manipulate time the same way that
like tony stark did during the events of
avengers end game is it one of those
things where he's just not quite on that
level yet assuming that scott lang and
hank pam have not mastered time travel
by way of the quantum realm then we use
the fantastic four for that in that if
my theory on the fact that either king
dynasty or secret wars is essentially
avengers forever whereby you get a
unification of different avengers from
across the multiverse the fantastic four
are the ones that make that happen the
fantastic four are like okay so we know
how to access the multiverse we can get
to other realities right we don't really
have to use the quantum realm per se
maybe once reed gets back he constructs
a device the bridge basically from
jonathan hickman's avengers really is
fantastic four run and then eventually
his avengers and new avengers run that
let them look into other realities so
they can observe and decide which one of
these avengers do we want that kind of a
thing and then snatch them up and bring
them in of course we'll talk more about
that during our our video on secret wars
and and kang dynasty and all that that
basically they're the ones that make
that possible so now because of them and
kang dynasty and secret wars you have
what's essentially a multiversal
avengers team right and then you just
kind of call it a day like i don't know
exactly what role they're going to play
here but i do think that there is ample
room to make a wildly compelling movie
and because of the fact that the film is
debuting at a time when we're in the
multiverse saga i don't think we're
going to be looking at a fantastic four
movie where it's like and then they
fight doctor doom day is saved it'd be
hugely underwhelming to be quite honest
with you guys i mean you and you have to
i mean surely you agree i wouldn't say
you have to but surely you agree with
this right like the phases ending with
king dynasty and secret wars the events
of loki have happened right we've seen
doctor strange multiverse of madness
we're in the multiverse saga it feels
like it'd be a huge letdown that like
the fantastic four film happens and they
just fight doctor doom it seems like
it'd be hugely disappointing so again my
thought on this whole thing is that it's
going to be the fantastic four right to
kind of sum all this up that the
fantastic four film is basically going
to be a film that's going to give us the
team that's initially time displaced
they explore the multiverse to a degree
they start to realize that the
multiverse is severely screwed up and
that kane the conqueror just there's so
many variations of him and that they're
in the middle of this giant multiversal
war they end up coming back to the main
marvel cinematic universe and they
become the center focal point by which
the forces that are made available to
defeat that are basically uh marshalled
together to defeat kang are all brought
together in the first place they
literally become the linchpin the center
point of the entire superhero community
which is what the fantastic four
essentially always were in the comics
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end let me know
what you guys think about this down in
the comments section thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace